Hello,
freak bitches.
Look for him like this is a win win.
I mean this guy's.
He's theater hulk.
Hogan is theater.
Everything is theater.
Did you hear the part?
And as in the questioning about his a 10 inch penis that he said yeah,
his hogs not as big as the games.
The game,
the game doesn't even have to go to court.
It's like look bitch know how big my dick is.
Unless it's a fake Dick,
the only thing they could do is they'd have to have some sort of a deposition
would pull it out,
shows you,
but he might be a shower and not a group or a grower and not a shower.
So like he might have to get worked up to prove it or you're completely right or
it's just fake.
He just grabbed some girls Dildo,
put in his shorts,
tick a photo just to make everyone go home and go to the copy.
You have a ticket.
I mean I've seem to connect.
Well that's you though.
You gotta understand you're unusual and it's not.
It's connected.
Like the Dick is connected to them.
Like if you look at it,
it's obviously like it doesn't look like a.
If it was a Dildo,
there'd be like a dropoff point at the base and you're like,
wait a minute,
how exactly is this thing attached?
You know what I'm saying?
But they didn't have the ones that you stick onto the side of the wall of the
shower maybe just went like on his.
Should be,
could be like he talked,
he talked and had that one too.
But even if he stuck it in,
it would be going forward.
It wouldn't be off to the side like that.
When you have spandex,
he probably just put it to the side.
It's one of those long double ended ones.
You know that the long snake one.
It's not connected though.
I,
look,
I stared at his dick very carefully
and uh,
from what I'm seeing it's a real dick and it goes with his body.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like Tony Hinchcliffe has a fucking oatmeal box in his pants.
So that's quaker oats box.
Somebody had the expression for it.
Somebody had that description I thought was the funniest description ever.
Quaker oats box for addict.
Well,
who is,
he's holding it even looks like him.
This is another one that's even faker.
Um,
no.
It looks like he's fully hard to tech guys.
Giant.
It's got a giant Dick.
Come on sign.
You know that Shit's real.
You want it to be real?
No,
I want.
I'm scared.
She that could just be.
Oh look.
He's got marijuana leaf tattooed right above his dick.
Like,
what's that supposed to mean?
Yeah.
Smoke it,
smoke it.
If he got the hashtags he has on there on his body
will change your life.
Drops.
Mike.
Restructure your day this Dick and keep them edges slicked down.
This dick can file your nails.
This dick.
This tongue will make you late for work.
Wait,
this can be your best friend.
This dick console and bundles.
I'm not sure what that means.
If you can.
I'll eat your pussy.
Oh,
you can take the whole thing.
Can you not?
If you can only Hashtag.
If you can eat your pussy till scandal comes back on next week.
He's
funny.
Tag Dick.
Game Strong,
I love that.
Let me tell you something.
Chocolate Hershey's chocolate with almonds.
Still to this day is fucking bang up first charter,
which America,
Terry Hershey's chocolate and Jif peanut butter.
Break off the fucking pieces of the Hershey's chocolate with almonds and dig
into a big Vat of Jif peanut butter cup.
POW for skippy.
You want to get crazy
when they try to sell us that bullshit where it was a stripe of jelly and a
striped peanut butter and a stripe.
Fuck you.
Unless you're eating with a spoon straight out of the jar into your mouth,
it's like,
no.
I decide how much jelly,
how much peanut butter goes on it.
This is stupid.
We're having a party for uh,
for.
This is not happening for my show.
Every Tuesday night,
12:30 AM,
three episodes left.
He has his color,
but anyway,
so we had s'mores.
We hit the back of Eric and sandy place.
There was a little fire pit,
smores and rock.
I just burned him.
I just burned the mushroom,
the mushroom marshmallow and stick it on there.
And then Scott,
Brian Ball journey.
He's like,
dude,
I was a cub scout for 12 years.
That's not how you do it.
Let me show you,
and for the next 10 minutes he perfectly browned this marshmallow from like
eight feet above the fire,
like just made it so long and they turn into goes,
see now this is a slapped it on there
that was waiting for her to finish.
He's the Franklins of.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Dude.
You just shit on the Franklin Morris.
I love slap people's heads.
I did it out of Gomez.
Had said he had an altoids tin that was open for so long.
Hey Mike,
why you leave?
You're making.
I don't want to do this too.
You're forcing my hand and then you just slapped it up and he goes to
the seller.
I'll look on the ground.
We found a lot of them
slept food,
so I would say it Josh Martin and did that.
He was coming out of the back with a fucking pretzel.
I'll cover with
just.
It's only great when they can easily replace it.
Yes.
So you've got to get here that five bucks back.
Go deal with it.
If I ever got a lot of money,
I would smash people's iphones and just stomp on them.
Here's $700.
But then what if they're in the middle of like a really important conversation,
right?
Babysitter.
Yeah.
Now you get it.
Anyway,
Josh,
mark comes out.
I just locked that it goes.
Oh.
And I can see he's looking at like,
maybe I'll eat it anyway.
You're making me step on this man.
Me Step on this.
You're leaving me no choice.
These are star.
These are the stars.
That debt.
So these purple ones are 200 milligrams.
This is what this is.
Take one of those.
I'll sleep for three days.
This is one to one.
Do you think you'd deal with this?
How many?
How many milligrams are in those 200 and this one you just threw a $200.
I had to go.
You got to go.
I don't want to take one of these days.
I don't know if you know,
but like an effective dose is 20.
What is he popping up to?
200.
Well I can't.
I can't.
I can't smoke.
I got the,
I could open up with three of these.
I can open up with 600 milligrams,
just
no idea how insanely good at bed at night.
Like a baby.
I put that mask on.
I sleep like a fucking baby sometimes I get paranoid,
my sleep and I wake up at three in the morning.
My heart pounds.
Wake my wife up.
I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you why I stay away from the edible because like I like to smoke at
night,
right,
right.
Alright.
So I got high one night and when I was at this one place,
they gave me some edibles.
They gave me a bag of popcorn.
Okay.
So I'm going to stand out and I just want something to eat.
So I opened up the popcorn.
Okay.
Now the next day Valerie is.
She can't figure out why I'm not waking up.
I slept for 19 hours and she found the wrapper under the bed.
She was starting to panic like what happened to it?
I slept till till midnight the next day.
She goes,
you wait for so big.
I said I didn't know I was stoned at.
I just want some need.
It was popcorn.
I didn't think they really like Hadley even getting into popcorn.
They make it with the butter,
the cannabis butter and they pop it in the butter and then they might even
sprinkle some butter on top of it.
Some cannabis butter and fuck you up.
Take on.
Now they had a benefit of pot benefit at the store and they were handing out
those bags,
bags of that popcorn.
It was fucking death.
Death.
We'll open it up.
It smells like scared.
Pure fucking weed.
I felt so vulnerable.
I just love how open it is now.
No,
it's great.
We can talk about a.
you're popping them like 10 packs,
but dice not everywhere else.
If you tried to do this in Texas,
still fucking die waiting for you outside.
Yeah,
but I have no reason to be in Texas.
You don't do shows in Texas?
I don't believe in it.
No.
I've gone to Texas,
but like,
uh,
you know,
in Vegas it's great.
Now that we're opening up places.
Yeah.
They got five stores,
right?
They haven't gone to any of them.
I normally bring my own stuff,
you know,
or if I go to New York,
I'll bring my own stuff.
It's one of the easiest businesses and that the at the end of the day,
businessman want to be businessmen.
They want to make some money and they.
They look at this thing and they go,
Hey,
do you have much fucking money they're making in Colorado?
They made more money in taxes in Colorado from weed and they did alcohol.
That's never happened anywhere.
That's definitely take wheat over alcohol.
Anything 100 percent because you know what I always say like with weed,
like a stone as you are,
let's say,
God forbid there's some kind of emergency.
You know what I mean?
Right.
You just throw water in your face.
It's gone.
It's not like alcohol.
You know where you don't know what you do it.
Right,
right,
right.
You know what I mean?
You could perform on the weeds.
You go bang on the weed.
You could bang more on the wheels.
Better listen to
you eat one of these doors.
Ain't no water going to help you fucking fucking fire departments that you're
reading like a pint didit stuff.